Okay. So we have dispatch instruction in ROB5.
It's value that it will produce is minus 1.
That value will be broadcast in cycle seven because it begin executed at six.
But before we get to that in cycle six we are going to issue this instruction.
In cycle six we have finished our multiplication here.
It was executing in cycles three, four, and five. Took three cycles. So
in cycle six it also broadcast the result. So the result of the multiplication
is broadcast as an eight under the name of ROB2 and this is marked as done.
ROB2 value is captured. This 8 is going to be captured here, because we
were waiting for ROB2. Here we are not waiting for ROB2 so everything is fine.
In cycle seven, the ROB5 instruction, broadcast the result of minus 1.
This minus 1 gets captured here because it matches this. And this instruction is
done. In cycle seven, as we have seen, we have written this result, captured it
here, we have marked this instruction as done, we have nothing left to issue. So
the question for you is in what cycle do we dispatch this instruction.